في خليج كومو إذا كان قانون لونا فيريتي
بيرناما دي فرنسا في الساعة 4 كانت الطائرة
في وقت لاحق أطلق سراح البحارة سيلين ل
breda 4 كما أشار مارتن
موفيلا الحمقى لأنه لن يكون شيئًا
موضوع الشاب يعود إليك بعد الآن
أوقف سيارات الأجرة ولكن اليوم
الصفقة فمن الضروري أن عند الخلق في
رئيس آفون ماري جين تظهر ابنه
يعمل على استيعاب أربعة عروض تجريبية مع
marionnaud djoumoi حار في لندن
انها تمول جديدة نقول السابق
رسائل البريد الإلكتروني الخاصة بهم إلى لامبريس فاناسي أثينا
إلى أين تأخذ الصين ayari لتسخينها
الفكيري أبيدجان 2006 يدا بيد
اليد إذا كان
بطارية 1b خادم كلمة katyn
أصداء العالم في المادة تكشف أ
عبود أبيدجان ومشاهدة العشيرة
هبطت زائير كولومبيا السابقة
أعيان لافالوا الخصبة أعرفني
mahiu in war gun جان تشارلز جيتشارد
[موسيقى]
وهناك الثمين لم يأخذ في
كهوف العاج هنا فقط في حالات التأخير
بامبا دامبام
مساء الخير
أنا التلكس الكامل وأنا من أبوبو
نعم أبوبو في ساحل العاج متى
تعتقد أنك غيرت الخاص بك أريد ذلك
المشهد تستمتع بذلك عندما نقول
مرحبًا من عشيرة السابقين إما أن تكون قادمًا
صباح الخير كيف حالك
ما هو الجو البارد هنا أتيت
لا مرحبا انا مثل هذا يثبت
الملاءمة الباردة تثبت أنها كانت كذلك
أنا مقتنع بأن في
أول مرة يحدث فيها تفاعل مع
الجمهور إذا كان يمكنك الاتصال
مصنع البلاط هنا تكسب عرضًا كاملاً
لذلك وجه تعابير ذلك البارد
لكنك سعيد مع الاعتدال
الآن بعد أن يمكنك أن تصبح مرة أخرى
كان بإمكان Finnair أن نبدأ نحن طفلك الصغير
يمكن أن تجرب هذا سيداتي وسادتي
من ساحل العاج
عدد الموهوبين
انت تتصرف
بارد في الواقع حتى سماسا بخير
تعال هنا أنا فقط التلكس وأنا
تعال من أبوبو هنا حيث سنصل إلى هناك
في الحقيقة قبل مجيئي كان لدي الوقت
لمشاهدة هذا الفيديو الخاص بالمهرجان
يوتيوب وعمادهم يعودون
في كثير من الأحيان أن الجمهور
مونترو خجول جدا المقبل
مدة المنصب
لا فمن المؤكد عند التأكد من ذلك
نقود القوافي لذلك هذا كل شيء
العيد ليس بالضرورة جدا
ثرثرة لأن لديهم الكثير من المال
لا تزال سويسرا تذهب هناك
بايلي في سهولة صفعة التجار
أن لديهم الكثير من المال على الحلقات
هنغاريا الملكية على كل ما فعلناه
الجسم قوي نضحك لأننا لا نملك
غير قادر على اكتسابها بعد ذلك لذا سنضحك
لذلك أنا أعتمد عليك الليلة
التي نضحك مثلها في إفريقيا لأنني
جئت إلى القافية البيضاء
وجدنا الشيء على الويب
لقد شوهدت مائة مرة على خشبة المسرح التي أعرفها
أني فجرتك
ننسى الألعاب الطويلة bli حقيقة ذلك نعم
لقد جئت للعب ضدهم هناك
أشياء لتظهر
عندما تصل إلى هناك يوم السبت ذلك الجاك
انت جيد
أنت بالفعل جيد
[موسيقى]
دعم عقلك قائلا أنا
الذي سقط عليه ثم إذا
المشهد الذي استقبل العملاء فيه
أنت الزعيم
التي تمنحك ما تريد
ضمان عمل الأشياء التي نعمل بها
صعب
[موسيقى]
ه
وشقة يا فاسي تحرر نفسك واحدة
تاريخ
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في الواقع نحن في الفناء الذي أعيش فيه
نشأ في الحقيقة إنه مسحوق
طفل هذا هو المكان الذي ولدت فيه هذا
هنا نشأت كل ذلك وهو هنا
حتى عندما بدأت أكون مضحكة
سنقولها هكذا وهذا هو الأمر
لحظة من صديقي etienne etienne في
كنا سويًا صغارًا جدًا
هناك من يحمل
أنا هنا في المنزل في الواقع
في المنزل أجد نفسي وأنا أزلت
صغير كل ما لم يكن كذلك
نحن نغسل الملابس كل شيء هناك
المطبخ في البطولة لدينا دش
في الأسفل
ليست ممرًا متباعدًا بعض الشيء
ربما التالي إن لم يكن
السرقات الصعوبات السعادة نحن
أبرياء
سوف نقول للأفضل أسوأ
بالمناسبة مثل حفل زفاف
في ساحل العاج عندما نقول آه أنت
إنها عنف إنها الريح
الفقراء الذين يعيشون هناك نفعل وهذا نحن
لا تستطيع رؤية ما تريد منه
كل شيء يقول أنه يأتي ليحبطك أنت أيضًا
تمر بالعنف لكنها لا تفعل ذلك
سيغير ما تتمناه فجأة
لا اريد انها ليست الضحك
[موسيقى]
إنها
لأننا نرى الرقص مثل الرجل الأبيض
يُسلِّم
مساء الخير هكذا ولكن وفقا ل
الجنة
هذا في هذه الحالة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الركبة لمدة عام على الأقل في فرنسا
وهذا بالتالي السباق ب ني
لعبة سيدي المعنية
لطخة بيضاء
الذي تحدثنا عنه دائمًا ولكني لم أفعل
لم تتح لي الفرصة لمقابلتك
وأنا أعلم أن هذا هو الحال
غالبية الناس هنا كبيرة
الطريقة فقط قيل لنا أن سانتا كلوز
تمرير هدايا
عيد الميلاد
ولكن إذا كان لدينا في منازلنا
لم يكن لديك الكثير حتى الجسم الصغير
لا تذهب
توقف عن القدوم لتسليم الهدايا 100
ز لأن نفسي جيدًا كان هناك
الدراجة ل
[موسيقى]
الدعم سيقتلون الصغار
المديرين التنفيذيين كانوا قادرين على سرقة المبدأ أثناء
شهر
حسنًا فجأة لا يوجد ذلك ولكن بالنظر إلى القلم
الدولار جيد لا أملكه غير موجود
هنا جاء لي
[تصفيق]
أبيدجان يومي الخميس 21 والجمعة 22 مارس
بجانب إيقاع المهرجان الأول
من الفكاهة الناطقة بالفرنسية من أفريقيا المسماة
كوميديا
أنا مقتنع بأن الكلمة يمكن
يغير العالم
ما زلنا نختار أ
ثلاثين شخصا لجعل
تظهر المواهب هنا نقطة
أفريقيا لديهم 10 كوميديا ​​من هذا القبيل نحن
لذا يمكن أن تأتي الكوميديا ​​من الألم
ألم في مكان ما
[موسيقى]
مسابقتان للمواهب الشابة هي واحدة
الاختيار لذلك سنجد شخصًا ما
من ذاهب إلى مونترو ومن ذاهب
عملت حقا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طيب ما لدينا كل واحد أو لا يأتي
تعال إلى هنا من فضلك لا
لا تأتي هنا
سنبدأ في رؤية أبيدجان ، دعنا نذهب
جاء للبحث عن فنان أفريقي
هي فريدة من نوعها من حيث أفريقيتها
حياته المهنية فيما يتعلق بهذا الرأي
العالم الذي نريد أيضًا أن نعطيه
حتى لو كان محليًا حيثما أمكن ذلك
لا يزال شيء اليوم
من هو فوق كل الأفارقة ولكن من
يبدو لنا أنه عالمي الليلة هناك
هناك فنان يوحد هؤلاء الثلاثة
المعايير وهو الذي سنختاره
ولذا فهو الذي عقد ذلك
[تصفيق]
هو ما هو مثير للاهتمام
عالمية قصتك لأن
الذي نعتقد أنه من خلال العمل على النص الخاص بك
ما زلنا نعمل الخريف يكون ولعبتك
كممثل قصتك التي هي بحتة
الأفريقية والتي هي سمة من سمات
أنت حتى لو لم يكن هناك شخص ما
في أفريقيا كان - اذهب أبوبو هذا أنت
يمكن مشاركة هذه القصة هناك و
عليك أن تأخذ الناس معك
تجد ضحكتك عليك أن تجد الخاص بك
لا تزال تجد كلماتك ولكن لديك
كل ما يتطلبه الأمر للقيام بذلك نحن
سيعمل ثم سيأتي إلى مونترو
معنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذه طريقتي المقدسة
وجدت الحرث
[موسيقى]
هذا هو المكان الذي أتيت فيه
بكيت جئت لأكرر
أضع ما جاء معروفا ما
تنتهي وسأموت
[موسيقى]
مع الريح بالكاميرا
للحصول على مصدر إلهام على سبيل المثال
أن لديهم هذه الممارسات ماذا
م
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير ، مساء الخير ، مساء الخير
أنا التلكس الكامل الذي جئت منه
احياء ابيدجان حيث هي دائما
ليس الحزب ما هو أبوبو
اليوم في برغس وكاتيا حيث يوجد عدد غير قليل
الكثير من أعمال العنف والاغتصاب
من التخلف والاحتشاء
لم يتم صيانته بشكل سيئ إذا كان كذلك
مسرح فيلم
القاعة مزيج من مدينة الله
ومذبحة بالمنشار
هنا تشاهد الآن إلى coire دي
كنوزه هنا في هذا المناخ
قد يبدو غير مستقر بالنسبة لك ولكن
مناسب تمامًا بالنسبة لي
جعلت كل طفولتي
[موسيقى]
الى
ذكريات مع أمي
ماميت لي كما لو كان لي أنها segou
متجر الكتب هو عندما تدفع بالفعل مقابل
غادي السعر الذي ناقشته يعمل
ليس لدي وقت هل الجو حار
أنت مميز لعبة إعادتها
السراويل هنا كل شيء طازج
حسنًا ، نعم أفعل
أضع اثنين نتوقع ذلك
إنه غريب غريب كما تعلم
لا وجه لنبذ لا لسنا
لن تفعل ذلك
هكذا
هناك هي التأشيرة هي تأشيرة الألعاب
الجدول هو جواز السفر
4:00 مساءً في كرة فلاش
3.0 وجه في المساء وبعد ذلك نحن حتى
تستحقون أن تفهموا تلك الانقسامات لذلك نحن
تركت في جواز السفر الذي رأيته
ما هو المنطق التعاوني الآن
هنا تأشيرات الهدف وبمجرد أن تذهب
longuet تأشيرة مخصصة للمحطات
طحن الهند تفكر في القهوة وبعد ذلك
الجنديين جواز سفر واحد
قرصة في سوف يرسلون ضوضاء
من الواضح أنه سيغلق
أنا
[موسيقى]
يمكنك أن ترسل لي الثلج والصوف
أيضا هذا لا
الحظر هو لعبة هنا م
كيف تبدين جميلة
اليوم
- mehdi europe هو نفسه الذي تراه
أنا صوت بالأحرى في الغرفة التي أنت فيها
علمني أن ألعب في غرف الملابس
حد ذاتها أمام ليستر انظر الأنواع لك
اذهب إلى الأدرينالين في العرض المباشر
وطن الإيقاع
وإذا كان كل ما عندي كان
التعبير عن العديد من هؤلاء
أطفال
[موسيقى]
لم أكن أعرف والدي أنها تعزفها
دور الأب والأم
في جناح باكاو ليست جميلة جدا
ليس خشبًا جيدًا في دقائق
وفيرة في بدء الاتحاد
سيتم تقديم غير مغلق أوروبا
Boisserie ، كان هناك 10 ملايين للاتصال
كنت مخطئا أن يكون الروح القدس
موجود على متن الطائرة
كل ما دعا لتحديه
التأثير هناك هو الله نفسه المبارك
من الله حتى القائد سوط معه
صحيح أن العام الماضي فقط تحول إلى
رؤية بصرية للرواية
ذكريات جيدا سننتظر
[موسيقى]
أريد أن أعيد كل شيء إليه وهو يفعل 1
لا
[موسيقى]
يجعلونك تسافر لكنها كذلك
معنويات السفر
أنها تحتل ارقام المسيل للدموع ط
سيحاول تطبيق كل de gaulle
المعلومات التي يجب أن أفعلها ، وإذا كنت لا تستطيع التقدم في السن
من أجل المتعة وقتا ممتعا
اللجوء يخبرك أنني ذاهب من أجل المتعة
هذا محظوظ في الحصول على إجازة ، نعم
نعم كان أحد الأصوات القليلة لـ
العطل في سويسرا توماس ما يسلي لك
نحن هنا نراقبك نحن ندعم بعضنا البعض
يمكننا بدلاً من ذلك أن نتفق على أن الهدف هو الخير
لحظة
حسنًا
[موسيقى]
أوه
ليست هذه النهاية
إنها تهبط على فرضية الضمير
من البداية
إنها فرنسا 5 تتجنبكم الفخاخ
لصفوف لا تحبهم
[موسيقى]
الذي - التي
صباح الخير
أنا تقنية نظيفة
يعمل السلطة نعم لي أذهب
الرحلات غير صحيحة ، نعم نعم
لأنك جاهز للمغادرة أو
أجسادهم شيء آخر
على ما يرام وفقًا لنشأة واين للسيارة
متوقفة في المكان فقط حتى أتحقق من صحة
يجب أن تخرج التذكرة كنت ذاهبة
طيب ومصر الذي جرح انه
أعطي ولكني لا أعرف أنني جربت ذلك
تمشي ترى كل ما يطول
ولكن في الحقيقة ليس من السابق لأوانه القيام بذلك
لنا لأنهم قالوا ذلك
بارد هنا اليوم لا بأس
هايدي لا تأكل وأنا يوم الأحد
خدّ
الأحد رأيت ذلك في الصباح هناك
ربما يكون هناك القليل من سد التنظيف
لكن
إذا كان الجو دافئًا بدرجة كافية ، فربما لا
ماذا
[موسيقى]
و
إنها 8:50 صباحًا.
[موسيقى]
نعم ، نصنع مستطيلًا
لكن مرحبا بالجميع
[موسيقى]
من الجيد حقًا أن أراك كما تعلم
لذلك نحن وفد
يصل مخصص من كيبيك إلى مونتريال
على وجه التحديد الشوارع
الطابق السابع وباختصار وصلنا مع
كمية صغيرة من المعرفة في
تعليم الفكاهة بسبب
هذا ما نفعله في المدرسة الوطنية
النكتة لمدة اثنين وثلاثين عاما و
في رغبتنا في القيام بجولة صغيرة في
الجدول لبدء نعم بشكل جيد فقط
تعرف على الجميع
يمكن لعالمك تقديم نفسه بسرعة
الذي قليلا ملفك الشخصي ماذا
لقد فعلت أنت حيث فعلت
بكالوريا إعدادا لمدرسة الآداب
التجارة أنا آخذ القليل وبعد المدرسة
لقد دفعت نفسي إلى الفكاهة
منذ خمس سنوات وما زلت ألعب منذ ذلك الحين
أربعة اليوم لدي
مشهد متقطع كما يقولون
في فرنسا وأعمل 80 سنتًا من التمور لكل
عام أو نحو ذلك مع العرض قليلا
في كل مكان في جميع مقاهي فرنسا و
من نافارا لدي عرض يتم تشغيله
كل نفس بوتيرة أقل من ذلك بكثير
أسرع منك
لقد أخطأت لمدة 5 و 10 في العشرينات
من التمور في السنة ثم الصواني
ثم أصرخ أسود ماذا
لكن لقد مرت ثلاث سنوات على ما أفعله
لعبة moci ضد عامين من المدرسة
الكلية وهذا العام هو الأول لي
العام في الحانات في مونتريال و
تقسيم برج ومحيطه في
منتدى كيبيك لو لي الأول الحقيقي آني
ملعب الوقوف
سأبدأ بالمسرح
عندما كان عمري 15 عامًا وبعد ذلك في النهاية
من المدرسة الثانوية في سويسرا سنقوم بعمل
عمل التخرج وأنا فعلت
يظهر رجل واحد في الواقع هذه هي الطريقة
لقد بدأت بروح الدعابة التي عرفتها
لا شيء على الإطلاق ليس ذلك هو
أول ما كان عليه القيام به لمدة خمس دقائق
وعشر دقائق لعبت فجأة فعلت
عش ساعة ساعة وربع
bah me لدي عشيرة من السابق عمري 23 سنة
تأتي من مسحوق يذهب على وجه التحديد إلى
بدأ العد التنازلي بالفعل في العالم الذي نذهب إليه
المسلمون وأثينا
ولدي ترخيص للجحيم الآن
هم محصورون في المسرح هو لي
أول مرة ضرع الشياطين
هذا كل ما أصنع مقاطع فيديو عنه
الشبكات الاجتماعية هنا لجعل الناس يضحكون
الناس ربما نذهب من أجلي
لا يزال لدينا جدول مزدحم
لذلك أردنا أن نبدأ على أي حال
وضع الأساس القليل معجم دانيال
فوق هذه الكلمات الرئيسية ليست قليلة لأن
التي يجب أن تكون لدينا نفس اللغة
حتى نفهم بعضنا البعض دائمًا
لفة السيناريو إعداده
هل يجب أن يكون أفضل الطيارين باللغة الإنجليزية
وبالتالي فإن الوضع في الكل
بدايات النكتة التي تعطينا
المعلومات التي نحتاجها
تعرف ما الذي يعطيني المفاتيح حتى هناك
قم بإعداد السيناريوهات بعد ذلك
الفرضية التي هي بداية du
محاكمة كاريكاتير ونبدأ
شد المرونة
وبعد ذلك تكون لكمة عندما تتخلى عنك
أنت الخريف على ما أعتقد فرنسا
لذا فإن المصطلح غير متاح حقًا في
طبيب أسنانها بالأحرى لكمة لأن
أن مقلاة من ضربات له بينما أ
الشيء الذي ينهار
توفري
شعرت أن طاقتك كانت تغني
يدرب
نعم شعرت أن الزجاجة كانت جسدًا
من والده كان يقدم عرضًا لهذه
السادة هنا عندما اليكس
مرحبا مرحبا انا جئت من الساحل
من العاج أنا زرعت السابق وهنا هذا
طائر السمان
نعم ، جيد قبل أن تحصل البندقية على الوقت
لمشاهدة بعض مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بالإصدارات
سوابق المهرجان على موقع يوتيوب و
الروما التي غالبا ما تصبح
هو أن الجمهور في مونترو جدا
خجول بينما تلقينا أبيدجان
المهرجان ونراكم على اليوتيوب
أيضا التعليقات التي قالت ذلك
كان الجمهور رائعًا إذا قرأت على الأقل
دعنا نذهب ولكن لا يمكننا أنت
أضف هناك جيدًا هناك فقر
لم يشرح في أنه كان سيأخذ
نهاية في أفريقيا هنا لأننا هناك
لست متأكدا من الأرز في وقت لاحق وهلم جرا
كل لحظة أو عندما تكون بخير
يجب أن تعرف بعض الأشياء الجيدة
لحظات
قيل لي أنك قادم للعب في سويسرا في
لا يظهر حتى في القارة القطبية الجنوبية ما عليه
الجو بارد جدا
كان باردًا أفترض أن الأرواح آنذاك
أن بعض معتقداتك هي كل شيء
أسس بالكامل ما هو غير واضح
أستطيع أن أزعجهم لكني رأيتهم
كل نفس ثم لا أريد ذلك
ابق هنا جيدًا حتى لو قمت بتأشيرة كل شيء
هذا لكنني فضلت الاستسلام وإذا كان
هناك أناس جاءوا معي
اكتشاف حي طفولتي جيد
هيا سأدفع لك الرحلة
خذ هذا الرقم مجانًا
7970 بدونهم اسمه مامادو هو
يعيش في تولون لديه صغير
قارب جميل جدا اعتاد عليه
لجعل الرحلة فارغة هذا ما
سأعطيكم سعر جيد سأعطيكم
نتوقع روبوتًا قريبًا جدًا ولكن إذا
لقد كان أنا
ثمانين شكرا لك
هذا مثالي
إنه تخثير ماذا يعني ذلك
يسمح لك بالمراجعة للشراء من هنا
مراجعة تتمة هذه اللعبة الرائعة
جميل أتساءل ولكن
ربما تساءلت في البداية
عندما تهاجم الجمهور وهو
مخاطرة كبيرة جدا القيام به بشكل عام
أقول علانية إنه ليس جيدًا
يعرف الجمهور أنه محفوف بالمخاطر حقًا
على نزع فتيل جيدا ثم ولكن أنا
اسأل حتى لو كان كذلك
إذا كان علينا أن نستهدف بدقة مثل
جمهور مونترو خجول
ربما أراد الجمهور السويسري
جمهورية لذلك أنا لا أعرف أنها
ربما تكون أقل حدة بالتأكيد من
يقول ما جمهور هذا المهرجان هنا من
لقد تجنبتها شديدة البرودة
مثير غير عادل انها لعبة خطيرة ولكن
ربما أقول أنني سمعت ذلك
الجمهور السويسري هذه هي اللعبة الأكثر عمومية
كانت أقل استهدافًا كانت مرات أ
فيما يتعلق بالجمهور الأفريقي ثم الدعم
من كل مقارنتك مع سويسرا
أفريقيا تعمل بشكل رائع
ربما يحتاج إلى التنظيف
لتنعيم الريشة في نفس الوقت الذي أريده
لا تؤثر على الكفاءة لأنني
أنه يعمل بشكل جيد
لكل فنان غرفة ملابسه لكل فنان
التركيز قبل أدائه وبعد ذلك
نحن محظوظون في سويسرا لن أذهب
أقول بصوت عال جدا 68 مايو ما يمكن
اتركوا غرف الملابس مفتوحة ولا يوجد أحد
الذي يأتي من الأشياء لذلك هذا رائع
هناك
جيد سهل وكذلك يجب عليها الآن
في الغرفة سنراهم هذه الغرفة
أسطورية سحرية
من العديد من الفنانين
حذاري
أصدقاء انتباه الزملاء سيدي
معي الغرفة الجميلة التي يعرضها
كوهم للجمهور
آه والغرفة
وهنا ديكور مونترو بالكتابة
مونترو
الأول
إنه جيد إنه جميل إنها أداة جميلة أ
لعبة جميلة جدا
اشتكى الاحد بذلك
وبعد ذلك يكون الجمهور يوم الأحد الثاني
الشباب يخرجون يمرحون ويضحكون
ستصعد على خشبة المسرح عليك أن ترى
الذي - التي
يسمعونني انه جيد
الصواريخ الأولى
هذا
أقل من النبي في 8 لغات
ل
أوقفه نعم في الحقيقة إنه شيء آخر
العالم في يده اليمنى
عندما تأتي على خشبة المسرح سيكون لديك
ضوء ولكن كل شيء وبعد ذلك لديك المزيد
أنه في نهاية شهر حزيران (يونيو) ، ستلعب لصالح فريق
الناس الصف الأمامي وبعد ذلك إذا كنت تلعب
كما لو قال مع اثنين انها لعبة
نعم ولكن هذا صحيح أنني لا أفعل
لا أريد ذلك في آخرها
كلمات ايضا
حزمة جيدة أقل تكلفة الذهاب إلى هناك
حظا سعيدا وبعبارة أخرى اللعنة عليه
هذا في المنزل نقول السيد باه نعم إنه
هذا نعم أعرف ما نقوله ولكن في
بالإضافة إلى أنه لدينا الكثير من الطلقات
قال ذلك من قبل كان محل الجزار
أي صباح في المسرح ومتى يكون
ستة أرجل ومع الفصل والرموز هو
هناك هذان المتران على المسرح
بالمناسبة ، هناك عدد كافٍ من الناس
عند إضافة الرغبة أفسح المجال م
إنه مثالي تمامًا إنه رائع وجيد جدًا
اللعنة هناك
حسنًا
whitera tenex ذلك
أنه في هيرفير مع 6 برد جدا يخسر
المفرط من هذه هي الأراضي التي تتحول
ليس عمومية ويقولها بهذه الطريقة
ليس
لا أعتقد أن الأمر يسير على هذا النحو
وهو ما يعني لأن ما هو
عن شيء له
يبدو الأمر كما لو أنه يقول كل شيء في نهاية اليوم
يدرك أنه يحب وطنه الذي يحب
من النسيان ماري لا تفهم أنه يريدني
الرمادي دعونا على العكس من ذلك قيد
لقد أحضرت الناس يجب أن يكون
هذا الخيط المشترك يجب أن يكون العرض
واضح من السدود من خيبات الأمل مثل
بابا نويل
ولكن هذا في النهاية عندما نقارن
مع أوروبا اللوائح ثم كل شيء
من الأفضل معه الشاي
يجب أن يأتي من مكان آخر إذا كنت تريد
يمكنني ترتيب شيء لك
التي نتفق على ذلك
نسأله أنه ليس كذلك
من الضروري الاستمرار في الحيلة التي يفعلها
بارد جدا في مخيم م لا يوجد
لا داعي أشعر بالفعل أنه كان بالأمس
إذا كان الأمر مضحكًا جدًا
يمكن أن يمر ولكن هذا مبتذل
ولكن من الممكن حدوث ذلك
لا حاجة لذلك لدي العدد الصحيح إذا
كنت أفعل هناك شيئًا يقترحه
رهيب
ممتاز ماذا تريد ان تقول
ما استورده المطورون
بلدك لا أعرفني هو بلدك
أخبرنا أنها لطيفة
التشغيل
إزالة الغابات والتصحر و
لكن الأسوأ أنه سانتا كلوز
عندكم
جربتنا هذا هو أسوأ ما في الأمر
كل سانتا كلوز سانتا كلوز
هذا وكان من الصعب ابتلاعه
هذا
بينما كان لا يزال هناك أسوأ ألف مرة
استغلال النفط تحت التربة
كل ذلك
التدخل في الشؤون الاجتماعية
السلام الاجتماعي للدولة نحن
السباق الذي نستطيعه في كولومبيا
لم يقل إذا كانت هذه القاعدة في الواقع الناس
صحيح أنهم قالوا أننا كنا
خلال ولكننا ما زلنا معتمدين
الهدف هو الذي يقرر
لنا ومن يقرر أنه واضح و
يقتبس وأكثر سوءا
الذي قمنا به
في القاعدة التي توجهها ليس
الانتخابات في الواقع
معنا هذه محتويات الأسرة سواء نحن
يرى أن لديهم القليل من الأوهام لتحملها
على الانتخابات لا تتطلب الجدة
لي ولكن هذا أمر إيجابي
أعتقد أنه ينبغي لكليهما
الأشياء السلبية طيب أنت الأوروبيين
جلبت إزالة الغابات شرقا
رسامة التعبير عن ثرواتنا
شيء آخر
مدرسة
سلبي
من الحياة اليومية المبتذلة حقًا للعملة
طرحوا - نعم نعم
سنضع اللغة الفرنسية فيها
العنوان في الأفق يطرح الفرنسية
لقد فرضوا ضرائب على العملة لكن الدولة
فرضت علينا بابا نويل
[موسيقى]
لذلك العلامة المجنحة ليس فقط
يسعدني أن ترعى ولكن ما هي
أحب أن أعطيك كل ذلك
ساعة
سوف تصنع ذكرى بالفعل في أسوأ الأحوال لك
لها إطاران بطلب أبيض
أنثراسايت
أنا
اعتقد أن
كل هذا
كبير جدا
ونرى dsi
ألفي و
ألفي يورو عندما تحسب
حتى حوالي مليون 300 لي
قتال يمكنني العناية أقل وأقل
ثلاثة أشهر وأربعة أشهر هكذا لا
كنت أتبع الأرجون
يشتري الناس عوالم 2000 هذه
يورو
أبوبو حتى شخص يعمل فقط
لا أرى السعادة مع الذئب في النهاية
من الشهر
ربما قلت لنفسك أنك لست
مشاكل
الشخص المناسب في المكان المناسب كل ذلك
ومن خلال المساعدة في نفس السقف ، نتشارك في
نفس المدينة نفس النفس والحياة
[موسيقى]
إنه وحيدا بعض الشيء
أنا أحب ذلك حتى الكائن المفقود
عادة ما ترى
أمه
كثيراً
قبل هنا ، وإلا فإنك تدعي
العملاء المهتمون بالعملة
بحيرة جبلية كبيرة تراها
كل شيء جميل
انا لست مرتاحا الله يحرسك
الأم بخير عندما نعمل
ماذا كنت ذاهب للحفلة وتلفاز النبيذ
line hameau هي ماركة إطفاء
هذا الفخر ل
انا هنا انا لست ابدا
المواد في سويسرا الجيش الشعبي تنتشر في العالم
لذلك لم يكن الأمر كذلك بالنسبة لي
ها أنت فخر العائلة
نعتمد عليك وقبلات المنزل
طفل صغير
ستخبرك على أي حال ليس أنهم
أخطأوا في تحميل هذا الوقت
يمكنك أن تفعل العالم كله
أول شيء يفعله هو النسيان
للبحث إذا لم تكن هنا
أكبر من السم
فانكوفر الشباب بالإضافة إلى العمر
ليس لديك أي تردد و
جورج مع
أعذار لأشياء خاصة
لتفعله معك مجرد إدخال
المدخل نعم إنه قلعة عادية
قرر أولاً باستخدام ميكروفون يدوي
لذلك تعود بالطريقة المثالية
لذلك سنفعل وسنكرر هذا
تسلسل هناك سوف تأتي من الجانب
حديقة لي سأفعل لوران الذي
لذلك الذين يقدمون قبلك مباشرة
جميع التعليمات للجمهور ويغادر
إعلانات أو موافق هنا وبعد ذلك
سنتابع سنرى ماذا
خلال عائلته وللسادة
يتركك قبل العيش في
عنوان الشركة
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير
الكثير من بريسيما في أمس الحاجة إليها
غدا كثيرا لهذا الترحيب أنا
أنا سعيد وأترك ​​أتيت من هناك
ساحل العاج حتى الآن تعرف
ليس ما قيل لي قيل لي
الجمهور في سويسرا خجول جدا
بالنسبة للجمهور في أفريقيا وأنا
أعتقد أننا لا ينبغي أن نلقي لك
حجر لأننا نضحك مرات أكثر في
أفريقيا نحن لا نمتص ما فعلناه نحن
ليس حقًا في شقة
على وتيرة ولذا حان الوقت
حيث نقدم كل شيء بينما في سويسرا
يجب أن تعرف بعض الأشياء الجيدة حتى الآن
لحظات كل شيء على ما يرام وبعد ذلك أنتم الأوروبيين
عندما تسمع عن افريقيا
تلقائيا بأفكارك عن الاغتصاب
تقاسم في التخلف ولكن
دعني أخبرك اليوم بذلك
كل هذه الأفكار التي تصنعها
أفريقيا حسنًا ، هذا صحيح
أكثر من يومين منذ أن اكتشفت
تمتص لقد راقبتك جيدا
آسف ولكن في الحقيقة أنا لا أحب سويسرا
الكثير من الأزرار صحيح أنه منذ كل شيء
صغير في حلم واحد معنا ولكن لا
بين البيض بعد ذلك مباشرة
تصبح بيضاء بالطبع
لكن لا بأس ، لقد غيرت رأيي
سويسرا راقية للغاية ، كل شيء مثالي
حتى أنني أود أن أقول الكثير لأفعله لشخص واحد
نفس البلد الذي كان علي أن أفعله عادة
هذا واحد يلعب هنا لقد صنعت اثنين للتو
هيا لا بأس ، هذا جيد بالنسبة لي وإذا
إلى جانب وجود أشخاص في الغرفة
التي تريد أن تأتي معي لوضعها
تغطية الحي الذي أعيش فيه ، لا بأس أنا أدفع لك
النقل قيل لي أنك كنت
كم هو في غرفة الحديقة 1700
حسنًا ، يجعلني أعود إلى المنزل لدي صديق
اسمه مامادو يعيش في طولون
إنه مالي إنه صغير
قارب جميل جدا بالإضافة إلى هذا
الذي اعتاد القيام باليورو عليه
رحلة العودة فارغة لذا فهي آمنة
أنه سيكون في النهاية سعرًا جيدًا ، شكرًا لك
الكثير من الاستماع لي
النباتات والحروف
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أنتم
ماذا يمكنني أن أفعل لأقع
نحن لا نهتم
الجزء نعم لماذا لا
إذا فهمت بشكل صحيح ، فهذه الهواتف أو
بفضل الرطوبة سوف ينتشر إلى
شدة الغاز حيث اللوحة
تبدأ الكهرباء دائمًا بـ
يقود هوليوود ويهتم بالأبيض
بالطماطم والقيام بالأشياء
صوص القارب انظر إلى طراز الطاجين إلى الأسلوب
راتاتوي و
أستمع إلى مقدار هذا
79 عامًا 79 حسنًا ، لذا فهو سريع جدًا
كلما طهيت مع المزيد
حكيم صفيق في الحقيقة أنه سيكون ذاهب
كن جيدًا كل الأطباق التي تذهب إليها
يقول إنه يصنع أطباق حقيقية كما كان من قبل
تماما مثل لا يظهر الماء البارد
أيضا لا صدمة حرارية
ثم بعد ذلك حقًا لدينا
الأشياء التي تكون أرخص على
يمسك بوعاء السلطة
هناك تخفيضات هناك أطباق
تأكل سلطة الأنواع الجليدية
الحبوب تفعل بالتخبط وفي الصباح
mousselines صنع غداء سلطة
الفردية وهذا يعد هؤلاء
هي نبيذ هذا انظر السعر
و 21 تنسيقات مؤامرة من مع
أعتقد أنك تريد أن تضع كم
معارك أخرى
3 لا يزال اثنان أو ثلاثة أكياس منخفضة
ثلاثة أشهر لا أفهم كم
المال هو وسيلة الحيوانات المنزلية
ليس أفضل تكتيك إنكار
تجارة
صامت وآمن لا يهم
سنخدش لك مرة واحدة
سرور
لن يكون لديك جافا المجانية
لكن كل ما ترجمته أنا
متعب وهو يظن لو هذا عزيزي
أنا ذاهب
[موسيقى]
عليهم أن يشموا عندما ننظر
من أليس
ما هو توصيل شيء ما
الشيء الذي تنقل المشاعر إلى
عامة إذا وصلت ستبقى كما ترى
إجهادهم بها
لقد كان سعيدًا جدًا لأننا أمضيتني
إزالة التوتر من الصابورة التي نسميها بعضنا البعض
ابق أطمئنك
قبل دقيقتين
على المسرح
ستكون الخيام الثانية لك
ربما ليست جاهزة
ما زلنا ننتظر سانتا كلوز في المنزل
نحن بفارغ الصبر نعم ولكن ليس من أجل
نفس الأسباب لأنك لا نحن
قال إنه سيأتي في النهاية و
يلعب مع الرنة له نعم DRM معنا
نسميها تأتي من الأدغال نحن
ينتظر أن يضعوا تهديداتهم على
اسلوب العالم انها جميلة جدا
في المنزل نأكل كل الحيوانات حتى
يورو مشترك الكلاب حتى القطط
اه نعم
و
فتح الأبواب أمام جمهور نانت
لا
م
[موسيقى]
أو
م
و
هو
[موسيقى]
م
لكن
يجب أن أفعل هذا في إيطاليا
عائق
[موسيقى]
أقول لنفسي أنه بخير ، لا يمكنك أن تشرح
[تصفيق]
القصة كن نفسك
[موسيقى]
أصدقاء
إنه المكان الوحيد الذي أصل إليه
أفعل ما
[موسيقى]
أيضاً
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أتساءل كيف أكون هكذا
المنتجات التي فرضتها علينا
الفرنسية أودعت التغيير و
بلدانهم
سانتا كلوز
[موسيقى]
gmail ويسمى براغ حيث يعيش
طافيًا لديه قارب صغير جدًا
بأصواته
وعلاوة على ذلك ما اعتاد عليه
belron رحلة الحياة في سي
مفضلة كبيرة وكذلك كل سحرها
إنها هدية
مشاهدة عضو ماسي وأنت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مرشح نظام الهذيان في القصر
كل الفضل في ذلك هو هز هذه الأوزان
[موسيقى]
كانت رائعة ولكنها رائعة لكنها كذلك
صحيح فقط لاستمرار السادة
أولًا ، هذا ثمين حقيقي
م و
[موسيقى]
و
إنها تجربة رائعة تعلمتها
أشياء كثيرة قمت بها
معرفة
يجعلني أرغب في العودة إلى المسرح
أوروبية لأنني أريدك
أرى لاعبين لكني أقول لنفسي إنني
لابد من الاستعداد بشكل أفضل هنا حاول ذلك
يخلص بشكل أفضل إلى المزيد من التصاق
صوت pouldu من افريقيا
جسدي ذهني ليس بعد
على استعداد لقبول ما يحدث هناك
أي درجة الحرارة الجديدة
اقتبس كل ما لست جاهزًا بعد
لأنني وصلت إلى سويسرا كما ترون
لا يكاد الناس لا يملكون
الوقت الذي اعتقد الناس أنه بخير
في العمل كل ذلك ولكننا نجحنا في ذلك
تعمل على صوتك ربما لأنك أنت
ليس لدينا وظيفة ولكن لدينا الكاكاو لدينا
قراءة القهوة ولدينا روح الدعابة
كل شخص لديه إحساس منا هنا
مثل
أحبها
[تصفيق]
م
[موسيقى]
الى
عابث بشكل جيد وقد استنكر الإيقاعات
قوم على نطاق الإنسان موريسي لونيلوا
ألكا فيراري كما قالت ابنتي بالفعل
منا للصلاة
[موسيقى]